[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone I'm Abbie short welcome to
Abby's kitchen with my baby finally
ready to eat real food and not just
mamas milk I partner with baby gourmet
who sponsored this video to help you
navigate
all this overwhelming information about
baby food and it's me again Debbie as a
health fanatic I've been getting super
anxious about the thought of feeding
baby Dee solids I mean there are just so
many toxins in our food system I can't
bear the idea of anything unclean even
gracing baby's lips lucky for you I've
been reading a lot of threats on my mom
groups and mom blogs to help figure out
what's best for babe oh no need to be
anxious Deb but I am eager to hear about
your plan tell me a little bit about
what you've read on dr. Google well
first of all my baby's not even going to
touch that infant cereal my dog's
recommended as a first food I'm planning
to do a baby led weaning where I let
baby take the lead with full non-toxic
foods not some man-made nutrient boid
carbs I mean I don't eat carbs why
should baby D that stuff is so bad I
might as well be feeding my kid box mac
and cheese those are some pretty strong
words Deb so I feel the need to set the
record straight there are a lot of great
different options for babies first food
and iron fortified infant cereal is one
of them it's easy to prepare
it's safe for baby and it's higher in
iron which babies have elevated needs
for after six months but what about the
arsenic I heard that those rights-based
cereals are loaded with toxic levels and
Abey arsenic is a known carcinogen
linked with cardiovascular metabolic
immune and respiratory related
conditions and I heard there's some
research that has found higher levels in
babies who are regularly fed rice based
infant cereal so what's the deal there
is no need to panic but definitely
something you want to be aware of rice
containing foods like infant rice cereal
do contain arsenic as well as other
metals like cadmium
and mercury in fact believe it or not
brown rice actually has higher
concentrations than white having said
that an occasional serving is really
nothing to worry about especially
because it's a nutritious and accessible
source of fortified iron but if you're
choosing fortified infant cereal and
you're not into the rice my go-to is
baby gourmets ancient grains blend these
are made with organic whole grains like
amaranth millet buckwheat and quinoa
with no added sugar or dairy they also
have to obeisance materials banana
raisin oatmeal and apple skin atomium
hmm good to know about the cereal but
what about fruits and veggies I mean I
hate the idea of feeding my babies store
bought baby purees that are loaded with
all the salt sugar and preservatives I
mean this is why I was thinking about
baby led weaning incorporating what
you're eating into baby's diet is always
a great idea but store-bought baby
purees can be a convenient and
comparable choice for busy families on
the go you just want to make sure that
you check labels and choose the options
with the simplest ingredient list I'm a
big fan of baby gourmets simple purees
because they've got no fillers or thick
nerves and no added sugars just tasty
combinations of real veggies and fruit
well I was all into this baby led
weaning thing but I'm starting to not
mind the idea of offering baby G a few
baby purees but wait a second I heard it
was impossible to do both at the same
time like with my diet it's all or
nothing right you actually can combine
baby like leaning and traditional spoon
feeding the beauty of baby led weaning
is that it gets baby used to a variety
of textures and purees are just another
texture for baby to explore I recommend
doing a combination offering some soft
finger foods as well as some purees that
way baby can learn how to feed herself
as well as learn those really important
oral motor skills like chewing and those
fine motor skills like picking up foods
as well as how to eat from a spoon you
can also just handle them how to let
them learn how to bring that food to
their mouth to eat it should all be baby
led whether it's letting baby eats off
finger foods or feeding from a spoon or
like any diet it does not need me all or
nothing here so it's really about
letting baby take the lead see what
works best for her well that's
reassuring but what about allergens I
mean I don't want my baby to have to
carry around an EpiPen in her purse for
her whole life I mean isn't it true that
you're supposed to steer clear of the
top allergens for at least the first
year of life
I get it can be really scary when you're
introducing one of the top food
allergens to baby for the first time
including peanuts egg milk tree nuts soy
sesame wheat fish or seafood just the
thought of having to deal with a serious
allergic reaction can be traumatizing
for a lot of us new moms but the
research and the recommendation is to
ensure that all the top allergy causing
foods are introduced ideally around the
six-month mark but no later than 12
months this is really the sweet spot
where we see the lowest risk of food
allergies when you introduce them it's
best to give just one highly allergenic
food at a time repeating for one or two
more days in a row to monitor for any
reaction before you move on to the next
highly allergenic food this just makes
it a lot easier for you to spot nicely
at the offending foods fast well that
makes sense with allergens but what
about everything else
I heard that babies can only eat one
food at a time it's not that mono diet I
was on in high school where he only ate
bananas to lose weight I lost like 10
pounds in a week
it was great I've had my baby also needs
to be on a mono diet right
no Debbie definitely no you nor your
baby will thrive eating the same thing
every day forever and aside from that
allergy protocol I just talked about you
don't have to separate foods at every
single meal like adults babies love a
variety of flavors and textures
sometimes separated it and sometimes
together so experiment to see what works
best for your baby and don't feel like
it always needs to be served plain or
all on its own so if you're serving
salmon it absolutely can be brushed with
some olive oil at top of herbs and
garlic and lemon or if you're mashing up
some broccoli you can totally throw in a
sweet potato I know baby gourmet also
has a wide range of really creative
puree combinations that babies totally
the only thing that you want to be
mindful of is that baby should not have
added sugar or salt but otherwise feel
free to do what works best for you and
works best for baby there really is no
right or wrong way to do it I'm sure
it's gonna be a learning process for
both of you
hmm well that's definitely food for
thought I'm probably gonna stick to my
all but in a diet this week but I'll try
to switch things up for baby G when she
starts solids this month well we're
gonna have to tackle you're eating
another day Deb but I'm glad to hear
that we clear things up for baby's first
bites a big thank you again to Baby
gourmet for sponsoring this video if you
liked it be sure to give it the thumbs
up leaving a comment below with some of
your burning questions about feeding
baby subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]